The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Let's get started.
So we continue our
discussion today
about light atom interaction.
And just to sort of
remind you where we are,
we started last week,
even before spring
break, to talk about
the matrix element which
provides a coupling.
So now we have a coupling
between the two states.
And we want to
understand what is
the coupling doing
to the system.
What is a dynamical
evolution of the system?
How does the atomic
wave function
evolve when we couple two
states using optical fields?
And well, as usual, we start
with the basic phenomena.
And this is we do
perturbation theory
with a dipole Hamiltonian.
And we have done that on Monday.
We've done perturbation theory.
And I made an
important distinction
between a monochromatic
case and [INAUDIBLE] case.
The monochromatic case gave
us in perturbation theory
this result.
And if you stare
at it for a while,
you see, well, these are
just Rabi oscillations.
It's not the formula
of Rabi oscillations
with the generalized
Rabi frequency
and power broadening because
it's perturbation theory.
So these are Rabi oscillations
in the perturbative limit.
But also on Monday I showed
you that for interactions
with monochromatic light, we can
just rewrite the Hamiltonian.
That it not just looks
like, it is exactly
the Hamiltonian for spin
1/2 in a magnetic field.
And we have already
discussed the solution.
So, therefore, we know for
monochromatic radiation,
we can just go beyond
perturbation theory.
We can solve it exactly.
OK.
So monochromatic
radiation we understand.
At least as long as we have
just the coupling of the atom
to a single mode of the
electromagnetic field.
And now we come back
to the broadband case.
I give a little bit more
of a summary and an outline
after I finish the
broadband case.
So what we have right now is
we have Rabi oscillations,
which we derived
for a single mode.
And the broadband case
is such that we now
assume that we have a
spectrum of frequencies.
And we assume that to be
flat and broad in a moment.
And what we have to
do now is we have
to substitute in
this formula the Rabi
frequency by the electric field.
And the electric field
becomes using the connection
between electric field
and energy density,
eventually the Rabi
frequency squared
gets replaced by an integral
over the spectral density.
It looks mathematically exact.
But, of course,
you all recognize
that I've made a very
important assumption here.
Namely, that there is no
correlation whatsoever
between the different
frequencies.
Because by integrating
here, I'm just
summing up the e
squares assuming
that there's no interference,
no coherence, no correlation
between the different
frequencies.
OK, so with those
assumptions I can now just
formulate the
mathematics exactly.
I calculate now the probability
to be in the excited state
by assuming we have this kind of
pertrubative Rabi oscillations
at every frequency component.
But we integrate
over all frequencies.
Any questions?
So now-- and this is where
I ended the last lecture.
And there are actually now, this
is really an interesting case.
I know I sometimes
spend a lot of time
on sort of where
the math is simple,
but the physics is
really interesting.
So the probability to find
an atom in the excited state
is now this function
which replaces,
which are the
Rabit oscillations,
convoluted integrated
over the spectral density.
And now we have to
consider two cases.
If this function is flat and
is spectrally very broad,
we can pull it out
of the integral
However, this function
here, which are your Rabi
oscillations-- sine squared
of an [? augument ?] divided
by the [? augument. ?] I've
plotted it here for you.
This function is
actually very peculiar.
It has a height of t square.
If you're doing Taylor
Expansion for short times t.
But the width is
t to the minus 1.
So as time goes by, it
gets narrower, and taller,
and taller.
And if you take t squared by
t to the minus 1, you get t.
So the integral
over it is just t.
So in other words,
we have a function
which goes as t square.
But the integral is t.
And if the width is so narrow
that the width doesn't really
matter, we can say this function
has become a delta function.
But the integral over
the function is t.
So it becomes t times
the delta function.
And now we the two
limiting cases.
If very short times t-- this
Rabi oscillation function
is extremely broad.
And at infinitesimal
times t, it is
broader than any
spectral bandwidths.
So actually what we
are doing is when
we solve this integral at very
short time, this is broader.
And we pull this
out of the integral.
And this gives us a
prefect of t squared.
So, therefore, the
excitation probability
is t squared times the integral
of the spectral function which
is just the totally intensity.
However, if you
wait a little time,
and eventually if
the time is such
that the time is longer
than the inverse bandwidths
of the spectral radiation,
then the spectral radiation
is broader than
this function, f.
And we pull this
out of the integral.
And then what we have is we
have simply the integral here
over the delta function
which gives us a factor of t.
So we have two functions.
And whichever is broader can
be pulled out of the integral.
And that means in one
case, we have a probability
which is t squared times
the total intensity.
And in the other case,
we have a behavior
which is the time times the
spectral density at 0 detuning.
OK.
So now let's-- just a side
remark before I interpret this
result, this function you
would recover actually the Rabi
oscillation.
I plotted it in
that way emphasizing
the amplitude and the width.
But if you look for fixed
detuning and you vary the time,
this function is
sort of spreading out
and at a fixed detuning,
you'll go up and down.
And these are the
Rabi oscillations
we have discussed for
monochromatic radiation before.
So these two limiting cases
are actually very important.
At very short times, the
behavior is, you know,
we have broad
spectral radiation.
But if the time is shorter
than the inverse bandwidth
of the radiation, even
the broadband radiation
is like monochromatic wave.
And the short time behavior is
t squared times the intensity.
That's exactly what we got
for monochromatic light.
In other words, if
you're broadening,
you have a broad
spectral source,
but if your inverse
time is broader
than the broadening of
the spectral source,
you're back to the
monochromatic case.
So a lot of people get confused.
I mean, I see that often
in part 3 oral exams, that
no matter what your
spectral bandwidth
is-- unless it's infinite.
But let's discuss a
pathological case.
For any broadband
light, at short moments,
the system evolves as t square.
And t square is the hallmark
of coherent time evolution.
The amplitude goes with t.
The probability
goes with t square.
And only when the bandwidth
of the spectral light
dominates when we can replace
this by the delta function.
Then we are in the
regime, which you all
know is Fermi's Golden Rule,
where we [INAUDIBLE] equation.
And it all comes
from this formula.
It all comes from assuming
Rabi oscillations.
But then performing
the spectral integral
over the Rabi oscillation.
This takes us from
the narrowband case
to the broadband case.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what says
the bandwidth here?
Because we assume
its narrowness arises
just because of the
short [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I will
use an LED which
has a few nanometer bandwidths.
Use sunlight which has a few
hundred nanometer bandwidths.
Whatever your light source is.
At this point, it's
a general discussion.
And I'm not going beyond
the two limiting cases here.
Of course, if you have
a complicated spectral
distribution, well,
you're on your own
to solve this integral.
But at short times,
we have this behavior.
At long times, we have this.
And the two regimes
are separated
by the time where I have
a crossover in one case.
This is broader and I can
pull it out in the other case.
This function is broader and
I pull it out of the integral.
And just where
this happens, this
is where we have the transition
from t squared to t behavior.
From coherent evolution
to rate equation.
OK.
Yes.
So let's now look at the
situation of broadband light.
Because later today I
want to discuss with you
Einstein's a and b coefficient.
A very classical topic
of atomic physics.
A very famous concept
introduced by Einstein.
And actually I want to use
the perturbation theory
for broadband light which
we have now formulated
to derive for you the b
coefficient of Einstein's a
and b coefficient theory.
OK.
So for large time, we
can now talk about rate.
Which is the probability
which increases linearly
with time per unit time.
And this was the
matrix element squared.
2 epsilon 0 h-bar squared, 2 pi.
The 2 cancels.
And then we have from the delta
function, the spectral density
at 0 detuning.
Which is the spectral density
at the resonance frequency.
So we have a rate equation now.
That the rate equation
is the b coefficient.
Einstein's famous b coefficient
times the spectral density.
And the b coefficient is
now the proportionality
constant between in
the equation above.
Which is pi d squared.
But now in all the formula
for the b coefficient,
there's a factor of 3.
Because the assumption is made
that we have isotropy of space.
The atom are randomly oriented.
And, therefore, dx squared
for given polarization,
the dipole moment projected on a
polarization of the light which
is dx squared is just
1/3 of the absolute value
of the dipole moment squared.
So in other words,
just to remind you
what I have actually
discussed is nothing else
than Fermi's Golden Rule.
And I could've reminded
you of Fermi's Golden Rule
where the rate is given.
I just use a standard
notation of textbooks.
You take the matrix element
squared, you multiply by 2 pi,
and then you have
a delta function.
And the delta function implies
a delta function is always
a reminder that it
needs integration.
So whenever you have a delta
function in Fermi's Golden
Rule, you have to integrate.
And there are two possibilities.
You have to integrate over the
spectrum of external fields.
That's what we just did.
The other possibility is, which
doesn't apply to what we just
discussed, that you
have to integrate over
a continuum of final states.
This will be important when
we use a Fermi's Golden Rule
expression to talk about
spontaneous emission
where we have a continuum
of final states.
So anyway, I could
have just said,
let's start with
Fermi's Golden Rule
and let's jump to
the final result.
But I really wanted
to emphasize here
the sort of intimate connection
between Rabi oscillation,
the t square
dependence, and how this
turns into a rate equation.
OK.
Let's just summarize what
we have done in a table.
We have seen two
different regime.
In one case with
the Rabi resonance,
we are discussing a single
final state of the atom.
A single mode of the
electromagnetic field.
All energy levels, all
states are discrete.
We are talking about unitary
reversible time evolution.
When we had rate
equations, we are
talking about many final states.
We integrate over them.
Or and/or many modes
of the external field.
We are naturally dealing
not with a discrete number,
but with a continuum of states.
The time evolution has
become irreversible.
And is therefore no
longer unitary evolution,
but it's a
dissipative evolution.
And all this came
about not because we
have spontaneous emission.
I will tell you
throughout this course
that spontaneous emission
is not as spontaneous
as everybody assumes.
Spontaneous emission is
actually unitary time evolution.
Unless you discard information.
But a lot of people think
rate equation irreversibility
comes from something
which is genuinely
spontaneous and irreproducable.
I don't know anything
in physics which
is spontaneous and
irreproducible.
But we come to that later.
And this is an example where
we obtain rate equation
by simply driving a system.
And the irreversibility comes
by performing the integral
over the spectral density.
So let me just write that down.
Due to integration.
Since we integrate
over an infinite number
of modes or states.
Any questions?
OK, great.
I wanted to make sure
that this is very clear.
OK, at this point,
let me just summarize
where we are in our discussion
of atom light interaction.
We've actually made
a lot of progress.
We have discussed
matrix elements.
We have discussed the coupling
of atoms to an external field
at the level of the
Schroedinger equation.
And we have done
perturbation theory.
And in perturbation
theory, we found
Rabi oscillations and
we found rate equations.
That's where we are right now.
So the feature now
which is missing
is, of course, damping
spontaneous emission
irreversability-- another
form of irreversibility.
Right now our Rabi
oscillations are undamped.
Whether we obtain them
in perturbation theory
or whether we use the
spin formalism to get them
in the resonant in the
strong coupling case.
And here, for the rate equation,
the way how we have solved it,
the probability to be
in the excited state
just increases forever.
The system will never
reach equilibrium.
But that means in both cases,
we have a missing element.
And this is
spontaneous emission.
So for the next
hour or two, we'll
talk about aspects of
spontaneous emission.
Spontaneous emission
will actually eventually
lead to damping of
Rabi oscillation.
And to a saturation
of the excitation.
OK, so we're now discussing
spontaneous emission.
And we will discuss it
in actually three levels.
One is I will discuss
Einstein's a and b coefficients.
I sometimes hesitate.
Should I really discuss
Einstein's a and b
coefficients?
It's sort of old fashioned.
And I have already in
perturbation theory
given you a
microscopic derivation
of Einstein's b coefficient.
But everybody who is
an atomic physicist
knows about Einstein's
a and b coefficient.
It was really a stroke
of a genius to do it.
And it becomes sort
of our language.
So what I'm doing here is
I'm not beating it to death,
but I give you sort
of a short summary.
It's also sort of I make a
few comments which is actually
amazing.
How Einstein actually got
results from the a and b
coefficient which you
can only get otherwise
if you quantize
electromagnetic field.
So it's also sort of
historically interesting
that Einstein actually developed
the theory of the a and b
coefficient before the
Schroedinger equation.
Before quantum
mechanics was developed.
And often you call Schroedinger
equation the first quantization
and the field quantization,
the second quantization.
So in some sense,
Einstein actually
preempted or had already the
results of second quantization
before first quantization
was developed.
Anyway, it's a landmark
paper, how Einstein did it.
And that's why I
want to discuss it.
But it's partially also
in order to give you
the historical context.
But then, of course, we want to
use the modern formalism of use
of quantization of the
electromagnetic field.
And we have already
obtained just now the result
for Einstein's b coefficient
by just looking at the induced
by the absorption rate
or the stimulated rate.
But then eventually having
a microscopic quantization.
By having a quantization of
the electromagnetic field,
we can also do now microscopic
fully quantum first principle
calculation of
the a coefficient.
So then we have already
the b coefficient,
we get the a coefficient out
of microscopic calculation.
So we don't really need
Einstein's treatment of a and b
at this point.
But it's nice to
see the connections.
So anyway.
So this is the agenda.
Einstein's a and b
coefficient to pull out
spontaneous emission
without even putting it in.
Then we'll talk about
field quantization which
automatically leads
us to a treatment
of spontaneous emission.
Any questions?
So how was Einstein
able to show that there
is spontaneous
emission without sort
of knowing the quantum
character of fields?
Well, the point was
he knew and understood
that there would be
thermal equilibrium.
He said, I know what
thermal equilibrium is.
Thermal equilibrium is
the Boltzmann coefficient.
A Boltzmann
probability for an atom
to be in the excited state.
The probability to be
in the excited state
is just the Boltzmann
factor and depends
on temperature in the usual way.
And he also knew that
the spectrum of light
would follow a
plank distribution.
And if you put those things
together, you go beyond that.
Because you are in
thermal equilibrium.
This here what we
derived so far does not
have thermal equilibrium.
And thermal
equilibrium only comes
through the damping of
spontaneous emission.
So, therefore, by Einstein just
using Boltzmann distribution
and Planck law, he got
spontaneous emission.
And this is what I
just want to show you.
For most of you,
it's a reminder.
OK.
Einstein's a and b coefficients.
I will post one of Einstein's
papers on the website.
He was also the first
to actually discuss
mechanical forces of light.
He realized that if you have
a gas at a temperature which
is different from the
temperature in the womb,
the gas has to equilibrate.
And the gas can only equilibrate
loose, excess velocity
by transferring its
momentum to the photons.
So some equations of
laser cooling, the fact
that light can exchange
momentum with a particle.
And this is eventually
what leads to equilibrium,
was already in papers at the
beginning of the 20th century.
And it's just amazing if
you read those papers.
How modern the language is
and how clear the language is.
But here, I'm not talking
about the mechanical effects.
But the mechanical
effects of light
which many people in this
class use for a living, this
is actually part
of this equation.
Because the equilibrium
between-- again,
I discuss here Einstein's
a and b coefficient--
the equilibrium between
the electronic structure,
the ground and excited
state with a photon field.
But Einstein also
considered the equilibrium
between the motional
degree of the atom.
And equilibrium between
the motional degree
of the atom and
the radiation field
requires the spontaneous force.
The spontaneous radiation force.
I'm not discussing it here.
But I'm discussing here is now
an equilibrium between ground
state and excited state.
So the probability to find
an atom in the excited state
is simply described by
the Boltzmann factor.
Now it's traditional
in the discussion
of Einstein's a
and b coefficient
to allow for degeneracy factors
at ground and excited state.
I have to say I
usually hate that I
try not to talk about levels.
I just talk about
quantum states.
Non-degenerate individual
So in that sense, I try
to characterize population
in a quantum state,
not in a level.
But it is standard to
follow Einstein's concept
where we have degeneracies.
I'm not emphasizing them
here, but I will just
write them down
where they belong.
OK, so this takes care.
We know what is a fraction of
atoms in the excited state.
So this is the equilibrium.
The next thing we
need is the light.
And Einstein assumed that
it's a spectral density
in a black-body cavity.
So we need the energy density
per frequency interval.
And this is nothing else
than the occupation number
of the mode times the
energy of the photon.
Times the density of states.
The photon number
per mode is just
given by the
Bose-Einstein factor.
Bose-Einstein statistics factor.
The mode density is, as you
know, in three dimension.
Omega squared, pi
square over c cube.
So, therefore, the spectral
density of black-body radiation
has-- and we need that,
and omega cube dependence.
And then it has this
Bose-Einstein denominator
in the well-known form.
So this is now Planck's
black-body spectrum
in the units where we need it.
So all we need is now to find
the famous Einstein a and b
coefficient.
We have to write down a
rate equation for the atoms.
So the fact is we know
already what equilibrium is.
Excited state versus
ground state population
is the Boltzmann factor.
But now we write
down a rate equation
which involves a
black-body field.
And then we compare the
solution of the rate equation
to the solution we already know.
And from that, we get
Einstein's a and b coefficient.
OK, so the change in the
population of the excited state
has three different terms.
One is the energy density
of the black-body radiation
can cause stimulated emission.
So, therefore, it's
proportional to the number
of atoms in the excited state.
The energy density of
the black-body radiation
can cause absorption.
This is proportional
to the number
of atoms in the ground state.
And then this
equation as it stands
would lead to contradiction
when I compare
the solution of this equation to
the Boltzmann factor we already
know.
And the only way to fix it
is to add an extra term.
Which is spontaneous emission.
If spontaneous emission
were not necessary,
this a coefficient could in
the end turn out to be 0.
Or it can be undetermined.
But as we see, it is
necessary for consistency.
So this is pretty much
the famous rate equation.
And we are interested in
the equilibrium solution.
In equilibrium, all
derivatives vanish.
And then by setting
the derivatives to 0,
I have one equation.
And I will rewrite the equation
by putting the spectral density
of the light on one side.
And everything else
on the other side.
And what we have here
is the a coefficient.
The ground state population,
the excited state population.
The b coefficient.
So this is the spectral
density of-- it's
just an expression for
the spectral density.
We want to put in now that
the excited state fraction is
given by a Boltzmann factor.
So, therefore, Ne over Ng
becomes the Boltzmann factor.
And, yes, there are
these degeneracy factors.
So I've pretty much divided the
denominator and the numerator
by the population in
the excited state.
And here I get Beg
OK, so this is the result
for the spectral density.
But we know already that
the spectral density
has to be of the Planck form.
So now we can
simply compare what
we know to what we obtained
from the rate equation
and make sure that it matches.
So it's good we have
the exponential factor.
And by bringing this
expression to the form
of the other
expression, we actually
have to fulfill two conditions.
One is in order to
make sure that kind
of the total expression is
OK, it gives us a ratio.
The Planck body
spectrum is normalized.
There is no unknown prefactor.
So this determines
the ratio of a and b.
And also since we have
this functional form
of the Bose-Einstein
statistics which
has this exponential
factor minus 1,
it gives us also a relation
between the 2B coefficient.
That one is the b coefficient
for stimulated emission.
And the other one
is the b coefficient
for force absorption.
OK.
So with that, we
have the relation
between the a coefficient
and the b coefficient.
And we find that the B
coefficient for absorption
and emission are the same.
Well, we know it's the
same coupling matrix.
I mean, the Hamiltonian
which connects ground
to excited state, excited
state to ground state.
But if you really want to
deal with degenerate states
and not formulated for states,
you have degeneracy factors.
OK So I could stop here.
This is sort of the
textbook result.
But I want to rewrite the
result that we recognize
the quantization of the
electromagnetic field.
So instead of just looking at
the power in Planck spectrum,
spectral density, and such.
I want to bring in
the photon number.
I've already given you the
Bose-Einstein distribution
for the photon
number in the mode.
So I take now equation
a and multiply it
with the average photon
number in a mode of omega.
This gives me on
the left hand side--
I'm multiplying this
with a photon number.
So on the left hand side, I
have a times the photon number.
On the right hand side, when
I put in the photon number,
the photon number
with this expression
just give me the
Planck distribution,
the spectral energy.
So yes.
This gives me the
spectral energy density
times the b coefficient.
Yes.
And this is nothing else
than stimulated emission.
So we realize that
stimulated emission
is nothing else than n
times the photon number.
The photon number n times
spontaneous emission.
Similarly, we know that
the rate for absorption
becomes now, well,
the same unless we
have degeneracy factors.
But just for the
fundamental discussion,
let's avoid the [? p ?]
counting how many
degenerate levels a level have.
Let's just assume we have
a situation that we just
count every state individually.
Then I can summarize this
result saw in the following.
That the total rate
for emission was
proportional to n for
stimulated emission.
And then we have the extra
1 for spontaneous emission.
Whereas the rate
for absorption was
n times the
spontaneous emission.
So we find that this important
formula that emission
has an n plus 1 factor.
Absorption has an n factor.
And it is, of course,
this extra plus 1
which was absolutely crucial to
establish thermal equilibrium.
If a had been 0, no
thermal equilibrium
would have been reached.
So in other words,
what is already
in Einstein's treatment
of the a and b coefficient
is that if you understand
absorption, which
you can understand with
the Schroedinger equation,
and you understand
and you write it
in the fundamental
way in photon numbers,
then spontaneous
emission is just
the rate of absorption
divided by n.
Spontaneous emission is like
induced emission in its rate.
But by just one single photon.
So as I pointed out, this
is a result which is usually
obtained with
second quantization
and it is already included in
Einstein's a and b coefficient.
So we could stop here.
We have already a major
result which is usually
obtained in field quantization.
But there is one deficiency
and we want clearly
fix it and move on to the
microscopic derivation.
And this is the following.
Right now, we really assume
black-body radiation.
And this ratio n plus
1 over n was only
derived for average
photon numbers
in a spectrally broad field.
And what is left for
microscopic treatment which
I want to present now is even
if you have just a single mode,
the atom can only interact
with a single mode.
We find that stimulated
emission and absorption
is proportional to n, the number
of photons already present.
And then there is plus 1
for spontaneous emission.
So in other words, we do it now
sort of microscopically again.
And what we get out of
it is that everything
we learned from Einstein's
a and b coefficient
is not just valid in
thermal equilibrium.
It's not just valid
for average numbers.
It's really valid for
single mode physics.
OK, so the agenda
is what is next.
Is valid.
4n.
So this expression
is valid not only
for an average over many modes,
but for each single mode.
Questions about Einstein's
a and b coefficient?
OK.
So we spend now the
rest of today and parts
of next Monday in a
microscopic derivation
of spontaneous emission
using field quantization.
But I just want
to make you aware
that we know already what it is.
We have a semi-classical
derivation
of the b coefficient.
And Einstein's treatment
gives us the ratio of a and b.
So we know already
at this point what
the rate of spontaneous
emission is.
But it is nice.
I think also important
for our education
to obtain it in
a microscopic way
where we really show how we
have to-- sum overall modes
and such to obtain
the expression.
Also I want to
ask you questions.
I want to ask you clicker
questions afterwards.
And one clicker
question for you is
what happens to
spontaneous emission
in one and two dimension?
Certain things will change.
And it's much clearer
what will change
if you have a clear
understanding how we sum up
all of the modes.
How all the possible
modes contribute
to spontaneous emission.
And, of course, in two
dimension and one dimension,
you have a different
density of modes.
So with that motivation, we
need a quantized electromagnetic
field.
Where we quantize the
field for each mode.
And then we go back, we do
the summation of all modes.
And we've really
understood in the most
fundamental and microscopic way
how photons and light interact.
OK, so our next chapter
is the quantization
of the radiation field.
We do-- yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
So when we compare the rate
equation and the distribution
of the photons, so there is a
parameter, t, in both of them.
So we just assume two
t's are the same because
of their reaching
thermal equilibrium.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean this is, of course,
what Einstein assumed
that the thermal equilibrium
for atoms with the Boltzmann
factor.
And the thermal equilibrium for
photons described at the Planck
distribution have to be reached
at the same temperature.
It was a
thermodynamical argument
assuming which
is, of course, one
of the tenets of statistical
physics of thermodynamics.
If you have two systems and
they interact with each other,
they equilibrate at
the same temperature.
Yes, this is very important.
This was a very
important assumption.
Of course, as we know, when we
have ultra cold atoms in a room
temperature vacuum chamber,
the atoms do not equilibrate.
But if you would trap them for
an infinite amount of time,
they would equilibrate.
It's just that we lose
the atoms from our trap.
They're knocked out by
[INAUDIBLE] gas collisions.
A lot of other things happen.
But if you could isolate just
ultra cold atoms in a trap,
they would stay in
this trap forever.
There would be no other effect
shortening our observation
time.
Eventually, the atoms would
just boil out of your trap
because black-body radiation.
Momentum transfer from
black-body photons
heats the atoms up
to room temperature.
And this is, of course, one of
the things which really amaze
people when laser
cooling came along.
You know, everything at low
temperature was cryogenic.
If you want to
keep a sample cold,
you had to put liquid nitrogen
shields, helium shields.
You had to put multiple
shields around--
if you had an
optical [INAUDIBLE],
you had a window of liquid
nitrogen temperature.
One window at
helium temperature.
Just to make sure that
the black-body radiation
is absorbed and blocked.
Because it would've been
absolutely detrimental
if you had a sample at
very low temperature
and it would've been exposed
to black-body radiation.
So it's really a unique
feature of the atoms
that they are, and this
is what you will calculate
in this week's problem set, that
the atoms are almost completely
transparent to the
black-body radiation.
They only react if the hyperfine
frequency or they react far,
far, far, far, far
off in the tail
of the black-body radiation
with an electronic transition.
But nevertheless, as
Einstein has taught us,
and as we know from
general principles,
this will not mean
that the atoms
stay cold and are decoupled.
It just means that it takes
maybe the age of the universe.
I've never calculated
the number.
It would really take forever
until the atoms in the atom
trap reach the
ambient temperature.
So Einstein's argument
was an idealized argument
which in practice
would never happen.
But if you exclude
all other processes,
you have a consistent
system by saying
I only have atoms with
their kinetic energy.
I have black-body radiation.
And everything has
to equilibrate.
And as I said
before, the argument
for Einstein's a
and b coefficient
simply assumes that the ground
and excited state population
equilibrium.
But you can carry the
argument even further
and say even the
Maxwell-Boltzmann velocity
distribution of the
atoms has to equilibrate
at the ambient temperature.
Beautiful argument.
And what you find
from this argument
is it's really amazing.
You find the photon
recall is h-bar k.
Einstein pulled it out simply
by making this assumption.
I will post the paper on that.
OK, field quantization.
We discuss the quantization
of the electromagnetic field
really from first principles.
From vector potential,
radiation field, Coulomb gauge,
transverse vector
potential, in 8422.
So we dedicate
one or two classes
to just discuss all
the steps to have
full quantization of the
electromagnetic field
with all the bells and whistles.
So sometimes when I
teach this course,
I say, well, you've heard
about field quantization,
I can refer to that.
Or I can refer you to 8422.
But in the end I thought,
why don't I just give you
a 10 minute derivation.
Just sort of focusing on
the essential because this
makes this cause
more self-contained
and more complete.
So I give you now a
ten minute quantization
of the electromagnetic field.
Pretty much going
straight to showing you
electromagnetic field
isn't harmonic oscillator.
And now let's use the
quantum description
of the harmonic oscillator.
And then we have a
quantum description
of the electromagnetic field.
So this is not rigorous,
but it is logically compete.
So we focus in the discussion
of the quantization
of the electromagnetic
field, we focus just
on a single mode of the
electromagnetic field.
Each mode will be an
harmonic oscillator.
And then we have many
harmonic oscillators
comprising the
electromagnetic field.
So a even single mode, we
assume that we have plain waves
with a polarization,
with an amplitude.
The electric field
is the derivative
of the vector potential.
And the shortest way
to show you an analogy
with the harmonic
oscillator is to remind you
that the total energy--
which is actually
if you're wondering
about a factor of 2,
the electric and the magnetic
part, the total energy
is quadratic in the amplitude
of the vector potential.
By the way, there
is a factor of 1/2
because if you have a
sinusoidal variation,
you take the time average,
cosine squared, which is 1/2.
Well, if the total energy is
quadratic in the amplitude,
this immediately allows
us to draw analogies
to an harmonic oscillator.
And we can use the
vector potential
of the single mode of
the electromagnetic field
to define two
quantities, q and p.
Let me write it in that way.
Omega q, plus ip, is related
to a in the following way.
And yes, I was just
ranting about this.
v is the volume.
We assume everything happens
in a finite volume of space.
Value would say I have two
new quantities, q and p.
So I need two equations.
And the two equations involved
a and a complex conjugate.
So now we had an expression
for the total energy
in terms of the amplitude
of the vector potential.
So now I can rewrite it the
amplitude square of the vector
potential is a times a star.
And with that I get
the total energy
to be proportional to
q square plus p square.
And that should remind you,
and if everything was set up
to remind you, that this looks
like a harmonic oscillator
where q is the
position variable.
And p is the momentum variable.
So now, I mean all
this is classical.
All this is just
clever definitions.
But now we have to do a
leap to quantum physics.
We cannot logically derive it.
We have to make a leap.
And the leap is that we
postulate that this should now
be described as a quantum
harmonic oscillator.
And this transition is
done by simply postulating
that the two quantities
we have defined
fulfill the canonical commutator
for position and momentum.
So we've started with the vector
potential, expressed the energy
as a vector
potential, and now we
say we recognize through
those definitions
that this is an harmonic
oscillator with variables q
and p which are defined in
terms of the vector potential.
So then you know if you have the
quantized harmonic oscillator,
you immediately introduce
creation and annihilation
operators.
Which are linear
superpositions of q and p
in the following form.
And a dagger has
a minus sign here.
And all the prefactors were
cleverly set up in such a way
that the commutator of
a and a dagger is 1.
And now we can do all
the substitutions.
We can express p and
q by a and a dagger.
But p and q were related
to the vector potential, a.
And the vector potential a
square defined the energy.
So now we have an expression
for the energy which
is no longer involving
a or p and q.
It involves a and a dagger.
And surprise, surprise, we
find that our total energy
because we have operators
now has become a Hamiltonian,
Has this well-known result
with the photon number operator
a dagger, a plus 1/2.
So this is sort of the
quickest way which takes us
in a few minutes to the
quantized electromagnetic
field.
Of course, all I
need is to come back
to spontaneous
emission stimulated
emission are the matrix
elements of this operator's
a and a dagger.
And this is where,
of course, stimulated
and spontaneous emission--
all that comes in.
The non-vanishing
matrix elements
in this description of
the electromagnetic field
are the ones where a
annihilates a photon
and the matrix element
is square root n.
Or where a creates a
photon, adds a photon
to n photons already present.
And then the matrix
element is n plus 1.
OK, so we went from a to q.
And p.
And we went to a and a dagger.
But a is also related
to the electric field
by taking the time derivative
of the vector potential.
So now, of course, we can
go from our expressions
of a and a dagger
all the way back.
Just substitute,
substitute, substitute.
And find an expression
for the electric field
in terms of a and a dagger.
The result is that we have
a and here we have a dagger.
We have a polarization vector.
We have the plain wave vector.
And the complex conjugate.
And the complex conjugate
of a is a dagger
so the electric field
is a superposition
of a and a dagger.
The electric field
becomes an operator
which is the sum of
creation-annihilation operator.
So with that, we can go
back to our Hamiltonian.
Our Hamiltonian for the
interaction between light
and atoms in the
simplest possible case
was the dipole Hamiltonian.
Which involves a
dipole matrix element.
The charge of the
electron is negative.
That's why the minus
sign has disappeared.
And now all we do is
from our treatment
before in the Schroedinger
equation where
the electric field
was an external field.
Now the electric field
becomes the operator
acting on the quantum state
of the electromagnetic field.
So by the way, this prefactor
here is because the rest of it
is just dimensionless.
This prefactor has, so we
have the matrix element here,
this prefactor is
an electric field.
And it's something you
should always know.
This electric field is
actually the electric field
of a single photon.
This is the correct
normalization.
If you want to factor out the
volume, the frequency, and all
that, you combine these
factors in such a way
that it's electric field
of a single photon.
Then we have the dipole moment.
And then we have an expression
with creation and annihilation
operator over here.
I assume now that the
atom sits at r equals 0.
So why should I carry
forward an e to the ikr term.
We conveniently place
the atoms at r equals 0.
But I have to say a word or
two about the e to the i omega
t factor.
I have been deliberately
cavalier about my formulation
in quantum physics,
of quantum mechanics,
whether I use the Schroedinger
or the Heisenberg picture.
And you know in the
Schroedinger picture
the wave function is time
dependent, not the operator.
In the Heisenberg picture,
it's the other way around.
And I have to tell you every
time I do a calculation
and look at it, I'm getting
confused about the two
pictures.
So anyway, trust me
that in this case when
I want to discuss the
Schroedinger picture,
the time dependent factor
should not be present.
But you really have to
look at the derivation
and carefully realize
the two are connected
with a unitary transformation.
You really have to
figure out in which
[INAUDIBLE]
presentation you are.
But I want to not focus
on the formality here.
But I'm not carrying
forward this factor
because I want to discuss
the Schroedinger picture.
OK.
Yes.
So now we can look at the matrix
elements of our interaction
Hamiltonian.
And just to be clear,
we have written down
this Hamiltonian for just a
single mode of the radiation
field.
Depending on what we
are interested in,
we may have to sum
over many, many modes.
So we are looking at transitions
from an initial state
which may be an excited state.
To a final state which
may be a ground state.
And since we have quantized
the magnetic fields,
we also have to specify the
state of the quantum field.
And we assume that the uncoupled
Hamiltonian, of course,
has simply number states as
eigenstates [INAUDIBLE] photons
and prime photons.
So the only non-vanishing matrix
elements are the following.
e is a charge.
e hat is the polarization.
Epsilon 1 is the electric
field of a single photon.
And, of course, we
only have a coupling
by the fully
quantized Hamiltonian
when we have a dipole
matrix element connecting
state a and b.
I mean these are all sort
of things we have already
discussed in another context.
But now the a's and a daggers
which only act on the photon
field, give rise value
to two couplings.
One is absorption
and one is emission.
Absorption takes place when
we look at the matrix element
when the final state
has one more photon.
And emission takes
the other way around.
When the final state has one
more, which way do we go?
Let me just write it down.
And then read it off.
I think I've inverted, but
anyway, initial and final state
can differ by plus one
photon or minus one photon.
In one case it's absorption,
the other case it's emission.
And the matrix element
is n or n plus 1.
So one is absorption.
And one is emission.
So finally if we ask,
what are the rates
of absorption and
emission when we
assume we have a situation
where-- and we have now
discussed the matrix element
and this matrix element could
become the basis of
Fermi's Golden Rule.
We just have to specify time
dependent perturbation theory.
But in any case, whatever we
do when we talk about the rate,
it will involve the
matrix elements squared.
So now we can ask
what happens when
we couple ground
and excited states.
And let's assume we
have an excited state.
And we sum over all possible
photon occupation numbers
of the ground state.
Well, when we go from the
excited state to the ground
state, there will be only one
term contributing to the sum.
Where we have one photon more
because it has been emitted.
So, therefore, because of
the square root n and n
plus 1 dependence of
the matrix element,
we find that for the processes
where photon is emitted, where
the atomic system
gives away a photon,
the sum of all the possible
rates becomes simply n plus 1.
And in the case of
absorption it becomes n.
So in other words, we have now
done the field quantization
what Einstein pulled out of
a thermodynamic equilibrium
argument.
Namely that if you have a
system that the rate of emission
versus the rate of absorption
is n plus 1 over n.
But we did not assume any
spectral distribution.
We know this n plus
1 over n applies
to every single mode of
t electromagnetic field.
Questions about that?
I also want to tell you, just as
a side remark, a lot of people
think that when
emission is n plus 1,
the plus 1 is different from n.
That this plus 1 is sort of a
spontaneously emitted photon
which has maybe
some random phase.
And the n which is
stimulated photons,
they go in the same
mode as they joined
sort of the identical to
the photons already present.
I don't see any of
that in that treatment.
So a spontaneously
emitted photon
is identical to the
photon which would
be emitted in a stimulated way.
You just have n plus 1.
This is the matrix element
for coupling to this mode.
At some point,
spontaneous emission
can happen in many modes.
And if it goes to
many modes, then there
is some integral or
some summation involved.
And this can cause a
certain randomness.
But at the level
of a single mode,
I do not see any difference
between the one photon
and the n photons at
this level of discussion.
Just keep that in mind.
And actually, we'll
discuss micromasers.
You can have put an
excited atom in the cavity.
And you have a fully
reversible exchange.
You spontaneously
emit, you absorb.
You have Rabi oscillations
which involve a single photon.
And they involve
spontaneous emission.
Fully reversible.
Completely
[INAUDIBLE] evolution.
So we have 10 minutes left.
Yes, I think this is just
enough to derive for you.
Now to derive for you using
the fully quantized picture.
To derive flow from
first principles
microscopically an expression
for Einstein's a coefficient.
So in other words,
what I'm doing now
is I really directly
calculate for you
the rate of
spontaneous emission.
And I'm not getting it
through the back door
by treating absorption
and then saying, well,
there's n and n plus 1.
Or borrowing some
argument from Einstein.
It's such an
important quantity, we
should just hit the
system with a Hamiltonian
and out comes a
spontaneous emission rate.
And this is what we're doing.
So the starting point is
what we have discussed
at the beginning of the class.
We want to discuss
Fermi's Golden Rule.
We want to use the rate.
And to remind you
the rate for process
is the matrix element
squared by h plus square.
And then we have to multiply
with the density of states.
So this is the
density of states.
Pair polarization.
Actually, I made a few
corrections to my notes
because I realize I
have be very, very
careful in telling you
what the states are.
Because this is what
this exercise is about.
And we are writing it
down for one mode by mode.
So the density of state
is now pair polarization.
We take care of
polarizations later.
Per unit frequency interval.
Yes.
So this rate, but now I
have to add one caveat.
I was just thinking how
I should express it.
This rate, if it's all
of spontaneous emission,
is the Einstein a coefficient.
But there is one caveat.
And this is the emission
of an atom which
has a dipole moment
is not isotropic.
So I have to be
a little bit more
careful with the solid angle.
I cannot just calculate a
rate and assume everything is
isotopic.
If I would do that, I
would save a few minutes.
But I would have really swept
something under the rug.
So what I'm calculating first is
the rate in a given unit angle.
And then I do an integration
over the unit angle.
And eventually I will integrate
over the dipole [INAUDIBLE].
So, therefore, the density
of the photon states
is sort of photons with their
k vectors go into all space,
but I wanted to have the density
of states per unit angle.
And this quantity is omega
square, 8 pi cube, c cube,
times v. And, of course, if
you multiply this by 4 pi,
you get your normal
density of states.
Because the density of
states is isotropic.
But the rate which
we calculate will not
be isotopic because of
the dipole matrix element.
And the dipole pattern.
So, therefore, we start with
a differential formulation.
Spontaneous emission
per solid angle.
And then when we do, when we
integrate over the solid angle,
we have to take care of a
sine square factor because
of the dipole pattern.
Good.
Now Fermi's Golden Rule takes
us from an excited state
to ground state.
And since we use the
fully quantized treatment,
our product states of atomic
states and photon states.
And so we assume we start with
an atom in the excited states.
And all modes, mode 1,
mode 2, mode 3, are empty.
And the final state, well,
one photon is emitted
and it can appear
in any of the modes.
And we have to do an integral
of all possibilities.
Good.
So we did all the
work with quantizing
the electromagnetic field.
Because we want to calculate
those matrix elements.
Let me just carry over the
prefactors, the electric field
of a single photon.
Here we have the dipole moment
between the polarization
and the atomic dipole
matrix element.
And now since we are talking
about an emission problem,
we have from the matrix
elements squared as we just
discussed, an n plus 1 factor.
But the population we
start with 0 photons.
So, therefore, it's just one.
So all the work we
did on quantization
of the electromagnetic
field is that even
without any photon present,
we have a coupling.
You can say it's a coupling
caused by the vacuum which
is like the coupling
we would have gotten
if we have exactly
one photon per mode.
So let me just write that out.
Yes.
I think we can finish that.
OK, we have now taken care
of the matrix element.
So we insert the matrix element
now in our Fermi's Golden Rule
expression for the ad omega.
Let me just keep track
of all the factors.
[INAUDIBLE] omega in
the matrix element.
This comes from the electric
field of a single photon.
We have a matrix element.
Dipole matrix element
times polarization.
And the density of states
gives us omega square.
So see already we'll get a
spontaneous emission omega cube
expression.
One omega comes because
the electric field
of a single photon, the
electric field squared
of a single photon is
proportional to omega.
And an omega square factor comes
from the density of states.
It's really important
to keep that apart.
The omega 3 dependence
has two different sources.
It's always nice to see that we
assumed an [INAUDIBLE] volume
and it cancels out.
OK.
Let me just write it down and
then we do the final step.
So if everything
were isotropic, I
could just multiply with 4 pi.
And the last factor
would be dropped.
But if you want to go from
the spontaneous emission
per solid angle to the
total spontaneous emission,
we have to average it.
And what has angular
factors is actually
the projection between
the atomic dipole
moment and the polarization.
So this is the relevant term.
And now we have to distinguish.
There are two polarizations.
One polarization,
the polarization
when we have a dipole moment.
And you have light which
is polarized in such a way
that the light goes here.
This is a dipole moment,
the light goes here.
And now the light
which propagates here
can have a
polarization like this.
Which has a projection of sine
theta, with the dipole moment.
And if the light goes there and
the polarization is like this,
it's orthogonal to
the dipole moment.
So the scalar product is 0.
So for one polarization, we
have a sine theta factor.
For the second polarization,
the scalar product
for the dipole moment is 0.
So, therefore, and that's
the last conclusion
I want to draw today.
Is this integration
over the solid angle
boils down to that we can
pull the matrix element out
of the integral.
And what is left is
the projection factor,
sine square theta.
We have to integrate over
the whole solid angle.
And this gives us 2/3.
So, therefore, our
final result is
that the microscopic expression
for the a coefficient
has its factor of 3
in the denominator.
And this factor of 3
only comes because I
correct the average
over the dipole pattern.
Well, then we have
4 pi epsilon 0.
I mentioned the
important dependence
on the frequency cubed.
OK, so this is our
final result for today.
And I will discuss next
week what are its units?
How big is it?
What is the quality factor
of the atomic oscillator?
But we can start next
week with this result.
All right.